Lombard les semis de mesclin se font à
la main on on fait petit à petit pour
être sûr d'avoir de la production tout
au long de la saison parce que je peux
pas faire tout d'un coup sinon tout va
arri en même temps symbole d'une
agriculture à petite échelle 2500 m car
de ser et de champ pour la culture de
légumes bio une aventure démarrée en
2016 à cortra pendant 3 ans le marécher
a pu profiter d'une période de test sur
une exploitation existante c'était
nécessaire dans mon parcours
d'installation puisque j'avais besoin de
me rassurer sur voilà ma capacité à
faire ce métier là c'est quand même un
métier qui qui nécessite beaucoup
d'engagement avec des investissements et
tout donc j'avais besoin de me rassurer
voilà sur l'aspect production sur sur
pas mal de choses avant de me lancer de
faire des investissements Aurélien le
premier dans le Loiret à avoir bénéficié
de cette aide à l'installation et les
terres qu'il cultivait gratuitement à
cette agricultrice sont aujourd'hui loué
pour une somme modeste c'est toujours
l'argent qui qui pose problème la
transmission c'est toujours un moment
délicat voilà pour que chacun soit en
accord que chacun personne ne se sente
laisé parce que moi j'ai envie que les
gens s'installent en bio surtout
aujourd'hui le marécher de 34 ans a
développé sa clientèle dans un rayon de
quelques kilomètres mais comme de
nombreux producteurs bio il est lui
aussi frappé par la crise j'ai commencé
j'avais deux magasins bio aujourd'hui
j'en ai plus qu'un et ça représentait
quand même 40 % de mon chiffre
d'affaires donc comme j'ai vu le vent
tourner on va dire j'ai développé un peu
plus ma clientèle de restaurateur
maintenant il représente plus que 25 %
donc d'année en année voilà j'adapte ma
commercialisation faut rester réactif
pour pour pas se faire avoir comme
Aurélien des dizaines d'agriculteurs de
la région ont eu accès à ces couveuses
agricoles au cours des dernières années
avec des taux de réussite de l'ordre de
80 %